here now is Missouri Senator Josh Hawley
member of the Judiciary Committee
Senator it seems like again the
two-tiered system of justice hunter gets
an agreement that would give him all
this broad immunity and meanwhile they
just keep piling on Trump from from
every corner yeah now Lord we're down to
charging the random people just throwing
those into the indictments is it any
coincidence that the doj rushes to add
these new indictments today after the
hunter debacle after their own
self-dealing and two timing is exposed
after they tried to hide from us the
true extent of this plea deal that gets
blown up and then it's like oh we got to
go indict Trump on something else I mean
it's so Brazen right now what they're
doing it is really a subversion of the
rule of law I mean they're taking the
rule of law turning it on its head and
Lord we just we cannot allow this to
stand the American people are not going
to be safe our rule of our our system of
government is not going to be safe if
this is going to be the new standard
Senator Hawley the situation here is
it's very simply stated
our department of justice someone or
some group in the Department of Justice
decided to give Hunter Biden a free pass
in this plea deal for all sorts of other
potentials be fair potential criminality
it looks like related to those foreign
payments that came into Hunter and and
others but that's a free pass that
doesn't happen
in these types of cases but it does in
this justice department how serious is
this yeah it's really serious and I
think what's even more serious or just
as Lord is the fact they tried to hide
it as you were covering just a moment
ago the way the government structured
that plea deal they tried to hide the
fact that they were basically giving
Hunter Biden blanket immunity and it
wasn't until the judge in open court
questioned them and said hold on hold on
what are the actual facts here doj was
trying to hide the facts I mean you talk
about again subverting the rule of law
we all know the only reason Hunter Biden
got this deal is because his father's
rich and the president of the United
States that's what this is about it is
two standards of Justice he should be
treated like anybody else Hunter and Joe
Biden Joe Biden should to tell us
whether or not he's a crook because the
truth is every day evidence piles up
that he was involved in these foreign
bribery schemes we need to know is this
guy a crook
uh the House minority leader Hakeem
Jeffrey spoke out today about this
indictment watch
the system
should just be allowed to work as
intended
and that means that the prosecutors
and
whatever judges May preside over the
various court cases
as well as the defense attorneys
follow the facts apply to law be guided
by the Constitution
Senator that's fine do they feel the
same way about the charges against
hunter or the investigation that
occurred supposedly into Hillary Clinton
or any of the other stuff yeah I agree
with everything he said the problem is
that's not at all what they're doing
what they're doing is is they're giving
Republicans one standard of so-called
Justice and then they're out there
giving a free pass to 100 Biden they're
giving a free pass to Hillary Clinton
and Bill Clinton by the way they're
treating parents like domestic
terrorists let's never forget this is
the justice department that sent the FBI
to parents homes to treat them like
domestic terrorists because they want to
go to a school board meeting let's never
forget this is the FBI that sent SWAT
teams to the homes of pro-life
demonstrators you talk about attacking
the rule of law that's what Merrick
Garland wakes up to do every single day
it is a travesty Laura he should go and
we need to find out Joe Biden is this
guy a crook this is an answer the
American people deserve to get the
result to
Senator very quickly politico's
reporting tonight that the White House
is very worried about Senator
McConnell's possible health problems
given what happened yesterday because
they would essentially lose an ally in
their work to try to block Donald Trump
they said having spent years as one of
the party's Chief villains McConnell in
the Biden era has become something
different a safeguard essentially
against a senate turning into a version
of the chaotic House GOP Senator do we
really think Republican voters want
someone leading the Senate who's closer
to Biden than Trump well I certainly
don't and I can tell you what the house
has the Senate doesn't the house has
what's called a majority the Republicans
are in charge in the house they're not
in charge in the Senate and I just say
Senate leadership if you want to know
why that's the case take a look in the
mirror
Senator thank you great to see you thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else